un cabas jamais vu personne c'est un
tabac appareils dans cette émission
c'est ça tu croirais comment ça va ça va
alors bon gogh
tu sais que ce film qui fuient les
clichés est déjà devenu un classique
malgré tout je sais que c'est le plus
beau rôle de sa vie ça on n'en sait rien
j'ai pas mal dans l'accident on sent en
sortant et pourtant ça ne change rien at
on inquiète une naturelle comme ça se
fait ça se fait que de toute façon déjà
au départ il faut van gogh c'est une
chose ou est ce que je joue dans le film
est autre chose oui c'est pas un film
genre autobiographique américanisé etc
etc
c'est pour ça que je la voulais
l'appeler dutronc van gogh peut-être
waouh même carrément mademoiselle de
marguerite gâcher vrai moi ce qui m'a le
plus touchée dans ce film c'était yeux
c'est les regards et j'ai lu quelque
part que il ya une scène quand tu
rentres de paris avec ma nouvelle gâcher
justement où il y avait prévu cinq pages
de texte et que finalement ça se traduit
par un parent regarde je pourrais très
pour le cas de la feignantise parfois
non j'arriverai à fait quand même deux
textes créés richaud apprendre le texte
pour se permettre de ne pas le dire et
je suis pas le cinéma ça sert aussi à ça
de faire passer des choses sans les
expliquer de ce côté là c'est très
réussi
bon bah tant mieux on va regarder un
petit bout d'accord
injuste de travailler comme un homme de
paix sans argent à soit gagné par son
travail
l'agent thèse par ton travail parce que
c'est toi tu veux m'entretenir ans théo
c'est fini je me sois mieux car ça et
dix jours c'est mme thibout de faux
après tout c'est tant mieux je vous
écris que tout va bien et elle se rend
compte de rien et regarde même pas ce
que je fais qu'est ce que t'en sais
s'instruit va très bien tout ça qui
soudoient qui disent que c'est mauvais
c'est ridicule était fort lui que pour
systématiquement ce à des fins non
j'essaie de comprendre par à comprendre
moi non mais c'est énervant temps de
raconter les choses que tu connais et
van gogh c'est pour une famille
d'artistes chantent elle regarde mon
père je vois pas ce que j'aurais pu
faire de plus sales de plus l'aide plus
inutile pour mériter ce regard là
j'essayais sérieusement et simplement de
prendre à ma façon
c'est tout bon jeu continue à quoi bon
continuer
l'habit trop le côté le côté peinture
tangwa c'est un peu quand même quand tu
en as entendu parler de ce film
oui parce qu'une des conditions fin
conditions c'est beaucoup dire mais je
voulais pas peindre
ouais ce qui me paraît quand même
extrêmement poli il lucide tu pense
qu'il vaut mieux fermer un tube ou
nettoyer un parce que c'est plus normal
quoi
puissant liées au temps je veux pas dire
que c'est plus normal c'est il faut
avoir des gestes vrai et juste un rebond
pense que savoir tenir un pinceau est un
geste juste si on sait bien le faire
quand il préparait le rôle daniel
auteuil lui c'était s'était mis à la
peinture comme un fou et c est toi tu as
toujours eu un certain mépris une
certaine ironie dix ans pour les acteurs
je parle pas de daniel mais pour les
acteurs qui par exemple de niro qui pour
jouer la motta prend 20 kg et tu as dis
bien un jour ils joueront les aveugles
alors ils se créeront les yeux quoi tu
penses pas que c'est comme ça qu'on
rentre dans un personnage
moi j'ai migré pour ça ouais donc déjà
vu l'a pas fait exprès non même si si
quand même mais le rebond en amérique on
aurait dit bravo ici on va à la vendée a
commencé par dire j'avais le sida que
monsieur coderre
ensuite ensuite ça a dégénéré en
tuberculose le sida cancer des zones
triple siros je pense que c'est
effrayant effrayant
donc là bas ils me payent par m enfin
peut-être survécu à bien leur montrer de
vrais médecins oui par contre il ya un
projet cinématographique que tu avais et
qui n'a jamais vu le jour
c'est cette histoire de pointu tu jouais
d'antoine non non pas du tout j'étais
derrière la caméra j'étais du côté corse
situé à la caméra était le continent
encore si tu veux et je voyais arriver
tout seul et tous ces gens qui
débarquait sur cette île bon c'était le
prétexte et personne n'a voulu produire
non maintenant - oui c'est ça avait pas
les moyens de produire pouvoir s'ils ont
de lourds effets non non non là parce
que la production c'est une chose est
réalisée en est une autre j'ai vu des
exemples de gens qui produisait réalisé
c'était assez compliqué car faut pas
oublier que le cinéma c'est quand même
deux largement débat télécommande pour
être accepté par les corses accepté
ouais j'ai rien fait je dois tu leur as
plus comme ça une non plus demain ça me
paraît très important puisque j'ai connu
tellement d'autres pays que j'ai choisi
celui-là
certains corps se n'ont pas eu le choix
moi je pense que j'ai trouvé là je me
suis garé là un jour la place est bonne
bon